if you need to get somewhere let's say a
new building put it into maps and google
gives you a route in seconds but behind
that seemingly simple answer is a
complex system of data collected from
users satellites cars even camels today
more than one billion people use google
maps every month and in 17 years it's
evolved from a desktop application to a
massive mobile platform that
continuously updates information about a
location we have over 150 million people
around the world that are contributing
information with 50 million updates a
day coming from the community from the
public sector so think of the map as
being alive but the amount of data it
collects has also attracted criticism
from privacy experts
here's how in google's quest to remap
the world it had to revolutionize the
technology we used to see it
this is the tech behind google maps
you can search for a place like an
address an intersection almost anything
when it comes to digital mapping google
wasn't the first on the scene or even
the second but when maps launched in the
mid 2000s it had technology many people
had never seen before
i remember the day that google maps
launched with satellite imagery in the
browser everybody
just went and looked at their own house
craig is a professor in the department
of geography at hofstra university who
studies data-driven geotechnology
no one had ever seen their own house in
satellite imagery much less in color
satellite imagery before this was a new
view on the world map success was partly
due to acquisitions it made early on
like where2 technologies and keyhole
that made mapping more accessible to
consumers by buying keyhole they got the
software that it took to have a easy
ready-to-use satellite image reviewer on
a global scale where two technologies
provided them a much better user
interface than was available elsewhere
and by combining those with just the
sheer amount of capital at google
allowed them to spend in ways and
develop those further that you didn't
see before
maps expanded its tech quickly opening
it up to developers integrating street
view and launching android and ios apps
early on
but how exactly did all this come
together to get you from point a to
point b
christopher phillips the current head of
google's geo division gave us an inside
look on the google campus
the foundational piece was to have a
real world model the digital truth of
what's going on in the real world
including where streets are let's take a
look at a real route in san francisco
that chris walked us through let's say
i'm in the san francisco ferry building
the farmer's market and i need to get to
san francisco international airport to
get that real world model chris was
talking about google starts with
satellite and aerial imagery to create
an accurate map this is layered together
with data from street view to do this
they use a process called photogrammetry
using this and gps data they can
pinpoint the right coordinates for the
image
if we take a quick detour off our route
to france you can see what the layering
process looks like using the arctic
triumph think of it as a big jigsaw
puzzle where we can put these images
together and we understand the distance
between images and where they sit with
the actual location the gps location
google keeps a range of the cameras that
have been used over time to capture
imagery at the street view garage on its
campus in california
it all started with a 500 pound camera
that was forklift onto a van you may
have seen a street view car at some
point with a 360 degree camera on top
some versions are equipped with lidar
sensors which measure the distance from
the camera to objects around it they're
also equipped with gps to get an
accurate location for exactly where the
camera is positioned but to reach more
remote places they've adapted cameras to
fit the terrain google has put cameras
on backpacks to get to places that cars
can't go they've also used
transportation like bikes and
snowmobiles in some rarer cases google
has gotten images from camels divers and
even astronauts their newest camera can
be detached from cars to be carried
around we graduate to our most recent
which is a 15 pound very lightweight and
that can be powered off of a phone
versus a large computing
unit that's in the car this imagery
isn't just for looking at it actually
helps keep their maps up to date by
detecting changes since the last time
images were taken we are not just
capturing what a place looks like but we
can detect that a business might have
changed we can detect new signs there's
now a stop sign here or a traffic light
here so understanding new physical
attributes of the real world is what
we've been able to derive once they have
all the information they need to figure
out what the map looks like google
layers on info about traffic routes and
businesses to do this they get data from
local municipalities public bus and
train schedules and businesses
themselves this is footage from 2013 of
the software google still uses to edit
maps a combination of machine learning
and map operators edit the public data
like road networks to match exactly what
you see on the layered imagery since
2013 google says they've been able to
automate most of this process
so for chris's route from san
francisco's ferry building to the
airport right now i can see that it's
going to take 21 minutes
in order to predict how long it takes to
get somewhere or how busy a place is
google relies on reviews contributed
information and anonymized location data
and uses algorithms to comb through
historical traffic patterns it looks at
current trends based on your anonymous
location aggregated with millions of
other users so we can overlay the trend
with the current activity to then create
a prediction the company also uses your
approximate location and its mapping
tools to target ads and advertise
businesses which is one of the ways the
platform makes money we have the ability
for
businesses to actually promote
themselves on the map so whether you're
searching for a place to go and if it's
relevant to the people who are in that
area we can show that as one of the
results
so far google has mapped more than 250
countries and territories but as it's
added more data and ingrained itself in
our lives and culture users and
regulators have pushed back and demanded
guardrails privacy is a big issue with
any kind of geographic technology and
google maps is only so much more so
because google maps is
down to an individual street address
down to individual people when we
connect it to things like your gmail
account or your wallet
or your wi-fi network google has been
criticized and in some cases taken to
court for things like the amount of data
it collects street view images showing
private property and grabbing data from
unsecured wi-fi networks with street
view cars google says the data from you
that it uses to inform traffic and
business is anonymized we use a
technology treatment called differential
privacy differential privacy allows us
to separate you in your activity from
what we aggregate from millions of
people
as signals to derive insights around
like busyness and how long the walk or
the drive may take but some data that is
used to tailor your personal map like
noting that you've been to a location
before isn't they say that that data is
not sold or shared with third parties
google also says that it gives users
privacy controls like toggling location
history on or off searching in incognito
mode and auto deleting location data
we're always improving how we manage the
information we capture to protect
people's privacy and make sure that we
only have the critical amount of data to
help power the most useful products with
this advances in technology its
advertising priorities and even its
criticism google maps has helped change
the way we navigate the world
the biggest improvement that google maps
has made is making geographic
information much more accessible to a
very large number of people the biggest
downside there's some thing paying much
closer to attention to the intricacies
of every movement you make when you
carry your phone google says the future
of maps aims to be more comprehensive
and immersive we're taking technology
where we can combine and fuse together
satellite imagery aerial imagery street
view imagery user contribution to create
a photorealistic view of what it might
feel like to check out a park what's the
vibe of it what's the vibe of it on a
different day immersive view is google's
next step in using their database of
information and imagery to map the world
[Music]
[Music]